why does everybody keep on hiring me all
of my work is shit hello I'm the
Nostalgia good guy remember it so you
don't have to and we're still in Shawano
a month you know when you think about
this guy's brought so much joy into our
lives most of the time so I figure it's
good to do a video celebrating his most
hilarious moments whether they were
intentional or not and my shamah lot has
created a style so convinced of its
amazingness that it proudly welcomes no
changes whatsoever
thus we keep getting the same mistakes
over and over allowing them to grow into
something so strange and unrecognizable
it becomes a laugh riot so the best
thing we can do is go over the funniest
ones and praise them for bringing us so
much enjoyment and we're gonna look at
the top 11 of them here today why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11 funniest
and night Shyamalan moments
oh well what the ending to the visit
okay if I want to be totally fair I
should also acknowledge the moments that
were intentionally funny what do you
like it or not most people agree that's
definitely one of his better ones and
that the best moment is in the end the
whole climax of this film feels like a
punchline to a perfectly written joke we
didn't even know was being told to us
even if you do figure out what's going
on that just makes the build-up all the
more hilarious like you peek behind the
curtain early but what you saw was so
fun you can't wait to see the rest of
the audience experience it it's one of
the few times that a perfect balance of
fear and comedy are projected on the
screen and both are enjoyably effective
I can't say too much more without giving
it away so let's just say you should
rent it and see for yourself those
who've seen it will probably agree it's
shit your pants funny huh let's see what
I did there those who saw it Shh
Seifer rate outside I still can say it
come to the clip of the puppet sorry for
Rage it's hard to say whether this was
shamans fault or not as Wilson it took
over a lot of the writing for this film
but nevertheless the name of Smith's
character in this cinematic bomb after
earth has got to be one of the silliest
things ever how could anybody say that
name and continue a sentence with any
seriousness if your Mystery Science
Theater 3000 fan like me you immediately
start quoting this Ridge large meat
flint iron stag both van der huge
there's plenty wrong with this movie but
by far there is nothing funnier than
just the mere mentioning of the
stupidest name ever put in his films oh
can we hear you say it again did not
well I'm gonna laugh no not
the twist to the village okay hold on no
screw it the fact that everybody could
guess this twist is what makes it so
funny the something that appears to be
in the 19th century in a village that's
out in the middle of nowhere where
everybody says you can't leave because
monsters will get you just from that
take a guess what the twisted you're
right your first immediate thought is
right
it's modern-day people without even
seeing the film got it already so the
ones who were foolish enough to sit
through this borefest were whispering to
themselves no it can't be just that
there has to be something else thus when
the twist finally hits it's not the film
itself against the laugh it's the
reaction of whoever you're watching it
with just try not to crack up when you
see your friends go what why are you
freaking kidding me just don't do it
dammit it's the twist we could so see
coming they were actually pissed off
that we got it ahead of time most of the
time we're usually proud if we can call
it but with this one without even seeing
the movie and we can catch on that's
just friggin ridiculous nevertheless the
reaction he gets from anyone who sees it
will have you rolling on the floor every
time number eight
this dumbass scene yeah but you didn't
know these bending masters have all
these abilities reduced down to the
equivalent of tapping sole on the
shoulder and appearing behind the other
shoulder this is supposed to be a giant
epic battle and we get this thrown in
how can you not laugh at something so
dumb that's it stupid
now listen the kids from signs it's not
big shock that people don't talk right
in a Shyamalan film but the extent to
which these kids talk is totally friggin
out there we're used to the goofily
overdramatic tone from his films but
these kids almost never act like real
kids everything people have written
about in science books is going to
change its rumbling Dodger barking oh
gosh oh stop it
it's almost like the children were
directed to talk like adults and the
adults were directed to talk like
children the history of the world's
future is on the TV right now who says
things like this you can't totally blame
the kids though as most actors have to
place a lot of trust in their directors
and Shyamalan has led pretty good actors
astray before just imagine the last time
you heard a little kid speak like this
we need to record this shake and show
your children this tape and say you were
there for your children buff and you'll
realize how hilarious this all is let's
face it hailey Joe Osmond faint I see
dead people
I see dumb writing noises
hot dogs I know I just went into this
with the happening review but I'm sorry
it deserves to be repeated this is one
of the silliest out of nowhere lines in
a movie everybody's on the run people
have to travel fast and suddenly this
incredibly important line is dropped you
know hot dogs get a bad rap got a cool
shape dick got protein you like hot dogs
right are you just setting up a tease
quirky like you tried to do with all
your characters well here's your court
she'll Milan you tere Reich were key and
thank God because if he could we won't
have something as laughably ridiculous
as this scene you like hot dogs don't
you oh and you want to know what the
punchline to this whole thing is get the
mustard get it cuz he likes hot dogs
did we make that clear they likes hot
dogs we can play it again what else can
you say but hot dog get the mustard
number 5
jillee side down that's right we're
going from one food to another there's
no excuse for this foolproof method of
determining if the devil himself is near
when he's near Tulsa foes jelly side
down that's right
if toast lands jelly side down the Lord
of all evil is upon you I know the
phrase how can you make this shit up is
a common phrase but really how can you
make this shit up it's a skill to make
up something so stupid why toast why
just one time you couldn't even throw it
up to test it a few times you just threw
it up one time and bam the devil is near
what the hell am I even talking about
it's goddamn toast it connects so little
to the world of logic that we live in
that you get a case of the giggles every
time you watch it so if you feel the
presence of Beelzebub in your house
don't get the crucifix don't get the
holy water don't even get the Holy Bible
all you need is toast
earthbending in the last airbender it's
no question that this movie is the
biggest letdown of shaman's films
because it took one of the greatest
anime shows of all time and reduced it
down to are you the avatar on that in
doing so it gave us a scene so
disappointing and so underwhelming that
you can't help but crack up and it's
lameness alright so a bunch of people
that can bend earth are placed into
prison surrounded by earth as if that
wasn't funny enough when they finally do
retaliate after Aang no I'm sorry pong
reminds them of the phenomenal gift they
have what do six of them gather together
end up doing even if you don't know that
the earth bending on the show has done
so much more for mere buildup of these
guys marching towards them just a fling
a pebble at them is phenomenal look at
that it won't crush wildly coyote it's
so measly I'd say balderdash if I
actually got to see a bowler - lame
the dumbest aliens ever everybody
insides is supposed to be terrified of
these creatures from another world but
when you really analyze why you find
there's very little threat to them not
only do they pointlessly graffiti our
cornfield not only do they set all their
attention on this one farm that poses no
threat not only do we find out their
weakness is water which covers the
majority of our planet not only did they
bring no weapons to fight our race at
all but the one thing these aliens are
always sorted by is wood yep
whether it be a wooden door a wooden
board pretty much anything from a
chopped-up tree will stop them in their
tracks if I told you there was an evil
force that wanted to kill you and it's
only weakness was water and would you be
as intimidated as well earthbender is
imprisoned by earth this is no doubt the
most pathetic invasion that has ever
taken place I'd be more afraid of a
spider climbing up my drain than these
jokers still their inability to do well
anything is certainly one to keep you
chuckling no go Oh Donna no me too
mark Whalberg from the happening yeah we
can't act like we can know what was
going on behind the scenes to give us
this performance but we can't say for
sure that it is one of the funniest
things ever look I don't know if you
guys have heard about this article in
The New York Times about honey bees
vanishing a lot of factors in Shyamalan
films are known for be misdirected and
turning in terrible performances because
of it
but easily the most entertaining is
Wahlberg if you somehow combined a lost
toddler with a lost dog and made it
obsessed with science for some reason
this is what it would act like I was in
the pharmacy awhile ago it was a really
good-looking pharmacist buying the
counter at first you think maybe it's
because he's a teacher I mean a lot of
times teachers have to talk in an
exaggerated tone even to high schoolers
but as the film keeps going
you realize this is his whole
performance toxin just going to talk in
a very positive manner it's so funny to
see this actor who is associated with
being a pretty talented badass just act
so intriguingly lost he doesn't know
what the hell he's doing he just knows
he's throwing his all into this
misguided direction and let's face it
it's spectacular it's not like he's
hurting for any future roles or good
performances but it is nice to know that
no matter what nothing will ever be as
enjoyably worse as this one what
no and the number one funniest M night
Shyamalan moment is the entirety of Lady
in the water
okay so everyone likes to say that the
happening is the best so bad it's good
Shyamalan movie well to them I say did
you even see Lady in the water well I
admit the happening is more consistently
funny the choice is made and Lady in the
water are so dumb so desperate so
perfectly insane that it's amazing it's
spectacular
it's
believable this isn't something where
you feel like a lot of people came
together to make a film this just feels
like a lot of people were following the
orders of a complete mental case total
insanity complete Looney Tunes anything
that will make a dramatic interesting
story is replaced with absolute
craziness it's mad ramblings of the best
kind is you know what I can't do it
justice here I need to do an entire
review of it yeah I know I know you hate
these to be continues and everything but
I'm sorry there's no way this film can
be summed up in just a number one spot
it needs to be looked at in great detail
to appreciate how frigging hilarious it
is even if you've seen it before and you
didn't think it was as funny as the
happening you need to see it with me
please I love the company I'll show you
the sheer lunacy and brilliance of this
masterpiece so stay tuned next week as I
look over what I consider the funniest
Shyamalan movie ever made
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I can't
wait no wait for it wait for it
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Shriners Hospitals for children these
are hospitals spread out all across the
United States Canada and Mexico
providing advanced care for children
with orthopedic conditions burns spinal
cord injuries and clutch lifts and
palate issues if you look at their
YouTube channel you can see all the
children that have benefited from these
good places and how much they've done
and on side note you should definitely
check out the YouTube videos because of
this one kid named Alec
he's like the main spokesperson for them
and by god he's friggin adorable
Fidel oh boy who's really good at
talking to the camera and it's that kind
of positive energy these places
constantly turn out this nonprofit
relies on the generosity of donors like
you so please definitely take a look and
see the good you could be contributing
to